i would here's the thing with that
though
he would have been called right he would
have be they're gonna call him racist
anyway how how has he not learned that
in the past three years going on four
years
they're going to call him racist no
matter what
if he started on monday or if he started
today
it doesn't make a difference
do you did you it's never going to be
enough they're going to call you a
racist no matter what they're going to
call me a racist no matter what they're
gonna call you a racist no matter what
because
my foot locker and my business insurance
it doesn't matter
stop caring
stop [ __ ] caring what people call you
i learned that lesson the hard way doing
this show
the first year of the show i went to the
more rally i covered it
i was trolling people making fun of
boomers
and at the end of at the end of that
weekend
i was in the splc's hate watch list and
they called me
my family's from cuba by the way my last
name is lopez
look at me they called me a hardcore
you could look it up the article's still
up
they called me a hardcore wife
my name is out there with me being a
hardcore white
you can't care stop caring what people
[ __ ] call you
doing the right thing doing what you're
supposed to do
shouldn't be incumbent on what other
people
may think of you or may say of you you
should do the right thing
because it's the right thing not because
you're worried about backlash
not because you're worried about what
people are going to call you a racist
if you're not a racist as long as you
know you're not one
it doesn't matter what people call you
because that's the whole point man
that's the point of the twitter culture
of the facebook culture of the internet
culture in general
of of of all of it is is that if they
scare you enough
and if they call you enough names you'll
walk away
with the [ __ ] your tail between your
legs and you won't say
anything because you're gonna be afraid
if enough people stop
caring they don't have that power
anymore
all of that then goes away
the fact that trump gives a flying [ __ ]
because of what jared's subversive
kushner says
blows my mind
enough enough
stop being afraid of what they call you
stop being afraid of what they say
it doesn't matter look at the people
that are calling you this
look at the lives that they live
look at look at what they want for this
country
who gives a [ __ ] what they call you
who cares
because you could pander to these people
how long have we been doing let's start
with the obama administration you could
pander to these people for 12 years
going on 12 years now
you could pander every single day
you could you saw the video of the white
woman that got on her knees because the
guy said i'm
black lives matter or i'm asking you to
get on your knees you could get on your
knees
you could kiss black israeli israelites
boots
you could do all that you could do
everything you want you could change
your profile tag you you could say you
stand in solidarity
you could blame yourself for something
you can't control
you could go on like these [ __ ]
celebrities do you could go online
and you could blame yourself for being
white you could apologize for something
that you can't control
you can't control who you were born to
you can't control what your skin color
is i
can't nobody can
it's not something you could do
you people are you could apologize for
something that you
can't have anything that you have no
control over to these people
and we've been doing it i'm not saying
all of you have but society has
we've seen it every day we covered every
day on this show we covered every day in
revenge of the cyst we cover it all the
time
and it won't matter because it's never
going to be enough
it's never going to be enough stop
trying to appease them stop negotiating
with emotional terrorists
don't don't negotiate with these people
it's not worth it for you for your
family and for the future
quite frankly for the future of this
[ __ ] not even country planet
don't you don't owe anybody
an apology for being born the way you
were born
you don't know anybody apology for
living your life
the way you live it you don't know
anybody apology
for locking your door at night you don't
know anybody apology
for living in a nice neighborhood
because you don't want to live in a bad
one
you don't know anybody in apology for
being upset that they're burning your
city down
you don't you don't know anybody an
apology for some [ __ ] stupid ass
[ __ ]
cop in minneapolis did you don't owe
them an apology
stop giving it to them stop
because they take it they wipe your ass
with it and then they enact policies
to make you poorer to make you live like
[ __ ] and to take away your freedom
enough enough
i frankly am done thank you pro-clutcher
i
frankly am done playing
your game this
is and i'm sorry i'm gonna get nerdy
here the kobayashi maru
you can't win it there's no way to win
this scenario
so the only thing you could do is what
kirk did
you [ __ ] up the very system
of the game you're trying to play
that's it that's all you can do
stop feeling sorry whether you're black
whether you're white whether you're
hispanic whether you're
asian middle eastern i don't care stop
saying sorry enough
but enough
done we all should be done
if you don't think the system is rigged
if you don't think the system is a joke
five days ago before this started we
were talking about the invisible enemy
in a virus
i haven't seen any newscaster not one
talk about this virus nobody cares
because in reality what we're learning
is if this virus was such a plague
no amount of rioting would oversight the
fact that there's dead people are dying
man
because it's not it didn't it never
mattered
it never was a real issue it never was
nobody wants to talk about the real
issues
nobody wants to talk about people odin
because of pharmaceutical companies
nobody wants to talk about china
basically controlling our economy
and buying out every other country
around them to make
to become one of the biggest superpowers
in the world nobody wants to talk about
them owning our [ __ ]
all of our medicine all of our ppe's
nobody wants to talk about that that's
uncomfortable and also because the
lobbyists control our government they
give money to these people and they make
sure they do it
nobody wants to talk about the money we
give certain middle eastern and not just
israel because that's easy saudi arabia
israel you give certain middle eastern
countries they give us
nothing in return nobody wants to talk
about us going to war and being a
perpetual war since the year 2000
continually for 20 years been at war and
having people dying over there for we
don't
if we ask them we don't even know
anymore nobody wants to talk about that
we want to talk about some fake racial
inequality in this country
to make some sort of point and at the
end none of these [ __ ] people
pandering hey black people i hate to
tell you this
none of these people pandering to you
give a flying [ __ ] about you
and if you think they do then you're
stupid because they don't
nobody cares and guess what white people
and right wing people
as we've learned none of these [ __ ]
none of these dan crenshaws
and [ __ ] conservative people in the
[ __ ] in in
in in the [ __ ] congress or the senate
and they don't care about you either
they don't [ __ ] care they care about
running the clock out as long as they
can and they get a cushy gig at cnn
or fox news being an analyst and if
they're lucky
they'll become an anchor
that's it
i understand i'm just a fat cuban guy
who tries to be funny on the internet
i get it and i'm not even saying listen
to me i'm a [ __ ]
maybe i'm a hundred percent wrong but
i'm telling you
how i feel i'm telling you that i've had
it and i'm done
give no ground give them
no ground they haven't earned it
they haven't deserved it they want your
trust
make them earn it because right now
they sure as [ __ ] lost mine